so it's been a little bit I'm sorry I
was in LA filming the you reviewers
Awards which went awesome it was so much
fun meeting all those really cool people
had a great time I'm back now and I want
to get into a new segment and recently
asked on my facebook what you guys
thought of me doing sort of like a
weekly movie news segment where I talked
a little bit about what I'm going to
review this weekend and then maybe
covered one or two of the industry's
biggest news stories of the week or
whatever and I think that'd be a lot of
fun let's get right into the movies that
I'm going to be seeing this weekend I'll
give you guys some quick thoughts about
them and as I'm talking about them I'm
going to have an annotation so you can
watch the trailer if you're into that
sort of thing let's start with movie 43
and the reason I'm starting with this
one is because it's the one that
intrigues me the most and I'm saying
that because I honestly don't know
anything about this movie it's like more
secretive than a JJ Abrams production
we'll talk more about him later but
seriously I really honestly don't know
what this movie is about and I kind of
like that because I like the idea of
going into a movie without knowing that
much about it it seems like a collection
of short stories and I know it's
directed by many different people I just
want to see something different now
apparently the movie is like super dirty
and outrageous now if a movie does it
right that can be a lot of fun you know
if it's not like in your face to the
point where you're like okay this is
just gratuitous then it could be a lot
of fun this movie apparently though
really takes it to the next level the
cast of this movie is absurd it's
probably the biggest assembled cast of
stars I've ever seen I mean I just took
a few names down here Halle Berry
Richard Gere Emma Stone Kate Winslet
Hugh Jackman Naomi Watts Elizabeth Banks
uma Thurman Justin Long Johnny Knoxville
Kristen Bell what is up with this cast I
didn't even name all of them I've Liev
Schreiber's in this movie even I don't
even understand how all these people
came together if this movie doesn't have
something good about it I'm also going
to be seeing Parker this weekend this is
the new Jason Statham movie with
Jennifer Lopez is directed by Taylor
Hackford the guy who made ray
interesting choice of film to be doing
because I'm sorry this just looks like
standard Jason Statham fare and I'm
actually a fan of Jason Statham I would
like him to do something maybe a little
less serious all the time I was talking
to a buddy of mine actually the other
day and he said Jason Statham needs to
fight monsters and I started thinking
about that and I was like yeah man like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and predator or do
some science fiction thing don't always
be like some bank heist or some thief or
some mob or something like do
something crazy and a weird and just out
there like that would be really good for
Statham I'm not sure about this movie
I'm interested in just seeing a standard
action film that could actually deliver
in some way I don't know if I'm going to
get that though with Parker it could be
fun
I'm not sure though who knows and lastly
the priority release of the weekend is
Hansel and Gretel witch hunters this
movie also looking pretty crappy this
movies pushed back a lot had a lot of
changes to it rating changes over and
over reshoots all different types of
things I'm not entirely sure if Jeremy
Renner is going to be able to carry this
movie and something about this movie is
just very often it's mainly the plot I'm
not really terribly excited about this
plot of older Hansel and Gretel I mean
like how many more stories it just seems
very silly and I'm just not looking
forward to it so the way I'm gonna play
this segment is after I tell you guys my
quick thoughts about movie reviews and
I'm going to have for you this weekend
I'm going to talk to you about one or
two big news stories that hit this week
and there's really only one worth
talking about JJ Abrams is directing
Star Wars Episode 7 this man has
officially transcended Joss Whedon as
fanboy God he's directing the new Star
Trek films and the new Star Wars films
but I got to say I'm pleased with this
because this is a man who's a fan of
Star Wars ok this is somebody who grew
up with it this is someone who probably
saw the prequels and went yeah that
could have been better this is somebody
who has it close to his heart this is
somebody who can make it good again I
just love the idea that they're going to
be new Star Wars films and I'm so glad
that JJ Abrams is going to be behind
them because he honestly in my opinion
has not yet made a bad film this man
knows what he's doing behind the camera
and I am so glad that they picked him
and with the writer being Michael Arndt
and oscar-winning writer and Lawrence
Kasdan the writer of Empire Strikes Back
writing the sequels to this film what is
going on it's like somebody just went
you know Watchmen yeah let's make some
good Star Wars movies you know what else
I'm kind of excited about I'm wondering
will John Williams scored this movie
something tells me he might not because
the composer that JJ Abrams frequently
collaborates with is Michael Giacchino
who is one of my favorite composers
working today and in my opinion on a
very equal level to what John Williams
was when he first
arted I am excited to see if it might
possibly be that Michael Giacchino could
score the new Star Wars films yes of
course it'd be great for John Williams
to do it and if they announced that'd be
like of course fantastic 100% yes but I
would not be disappointed if they
announced that Michael Giacchino would
be doing that score as well I don't know
if they'll maintain the same Star Wars
theme or if they make up a new theme if
I was a composer and I was to sit in
front of a piece of paper and go how do
I write a new Star Wars theme I just my
mind would explode I don't know what
would be going on I'm still honestly
fresh off the news that there will be a
new Star Wars film in 2015 it's only two
years away it's like I'm still being
affected by that piece of news I don't
even know what's going on now it's
directed by JJ Abrams I was singing by
my computer like not only what to do
like I was gonna explode all over the
place poop flying everywhere
I am extremely pumped for the idea of a
new Star Wars film I'm extremely happy
that JJ Abrams is directing it some
people like oh well you can't direct
Star Trek and Star Wars and I understand
that complaint in my opinion there are
two different types of fanboys fanboy
number one and fanboy number two I am
number one that fanboy is the kind of
guy who gets really excited about
projects like this like The Avengers of
The Dark Knight Rises or Star Wars he or
she wants to see those projects handled
well and they want to turn out well in
they're really excited to see them and
they just want good people involved with
those projects and then there's fanboy
number two and that person only wants it
to be exactly the way he wants it if
they deviate from the comic books in any
way that person will then rape and
boycott that filmmaker if the wrong
filmmaker chooses the project who may be
involved with another project that he
doesn't want to be involved with he will
then find and kill that filmmaker there
are a lot of fanboy number twos out
there who are upset about JJ Abrams
directing Star Wars because of the fact
that he also is directing the Star Trek
films I'm not one of those people and
not to say that you are less of a person
if you're fanboy - that's fine this is
just a stupid little illustration I made
up in two seconds and I hope you agree
with me on it but seriously guys thanks
a lot for watching I really appreciate
it I'm going to be back pretty soon as
more movie news I'll be back with
reviews of movie 43 Parker and Hansel
and Gretel this weekend look forward to
those and as always guys if you like
this video you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]